okay so this is the March Journal this
journal is actually longer it's nearly
an hour but I didn't want to divide it
into two halves so I figured I'll just
you have an hour video so hopefully you
don't get bored with me within the hour
there's a bit of Emerald City Comicon
bit of Vegas so it's entertaining I
could say that so I hope you enjoy it
and this month we'll start out as many
months have in the history of humanity
and that is my friend and I playing
Super Mario Brothers too I feel like
danger should give you a transition now
because it's tradition we're gonna get
three cherries eventually Hey all right
and you create the save point
look we've put in our time just help we
do it now John long third charity yes
I'm a big lemmings kick I didn't know
there was one for PlayStation 1 so I got
it and this is fun I love lemmings about
to head out to the Captain Marvel
screening and I think I got a couple
hours of sleep last night it's a it's an
earlier screening so it's like 8 a.m.
right now I'm pretty sure Ramsay like at
like 5 I went to sleep at about 1 or 2
anyhow let's go alright so just got out
of Captain Marvel and it was just okay
so my review will please nobody
and I feel like making my review can be
that thing that really unites all sides
everyone gonna be like well [ __ ] that
guy's review because he didn't love it
the other half be like [ __ ] that guy he
didn't hate it and then everyone can
come together to fight the greater evil
which is me I guess or the greater sense
of indifference to a movie that I
thought was okay I'll pick up the
cabinets on the way back from the screen
from Ikea should be a quick in-and-out -
I said Batman Begins answered the
question why do we fall the answer is we
can pick ourselves back up
I now answer the question why do you
have cats you dislike what the [ __ ] kita
kita surprisingly fast yeah for her yeah
her little fat arms are really fast just
saying look at all this fur on the
ground it looks exactly like my living
room but it's cat fur instead of dog fur
it's March the continuing Adventures of
the Frost sausage snowing again
Vanessa even my dogs are freaking out
Vanessa to show how much he cares told
Alexa to play baby shark it's about 5:40
in the morning and I was up all night
doing my Captain Marvel spoiler video
you know that one took me a while he
want to phrase everything correctly and
whatnot so I'm laying in bed I scheduled
it to go live at 6:00 a.m. and I realize
that I well if you want a strong female
character to run the Avengers go for it
Black Widow and then I was like if you
want a strong female character to kill
go for it Scarlet Witch and as I'm
laying here in bed my videos uploaded
gonna go live at 6 a.m. and I realize
wait a minute Scarlet Witch died with
the snap so I had to delete that go have
stairs edit it re-export it which takes
about 40 minutes and then I'll reload it
I think God this is my dad and I
shopping records I don't own this and
that's weird
it's in here doc how's it look next pops
[Music]
holy crap this takes me back as gypsy
and I are here to tell you this is not a
drill there is a trailer with gypsies
going nuts gypsy and I are here to tell
you well now I'm here to tell you this
is not a drill there is a trailer to
Cobra Kai season 2 and it looks [ __ ]
it's just a surprisingly good show
there's been my day for the last couple
days some destiny - didn't play it then
I got it for free when I picked up
spider-man they were like hey here's a
free Chestatee game so like alright
guess they're trying to get rid or
something or at least promote and
expansion anyhow it's for so much reason
I'm doing a video on the Aladdin trailer
and first upload just stuck at
processing second upload stuck at
uploading I don't know if it's my
computer or YouTube or whatever so
here's to the third upload attempt after
cycle in my computer's power hmm it's up
to three upload attempts on Google
Chrome on my laptop and then Internet
Explorer on my laptop I went to my
desktop uploaded it there it's frozen
processing I googled it weird like as
soon as three minutes ago people are
like I'm having trouble uploading here
let anyone else have this problem so
apparently it's a YouTube thing like
we're talking nationwide that's strange
will YouTube's [ __ ] today so I'm back
to playing destiny tier which I have
played so much destiny to in the last
couple days my thumb hurts so bad I've
experienced that or the game in quite
some time it's like your grind man I've
never problem you have a problem well
video went up took a couple hours and
now people will know my thoughts on the
new Aladdin trailer that was weird
though doctor playing destiny for days I
pretty much reached the cap on vanilla
destiny I was like oh man I got it by
the DLC it's nothing
that's why you're giving it away for
free smart very smart so we bought a new
ball that ball gypsy was chewing on her
forever
and so dangers over here just crushed
and mopey about it it's like it's SAP
it's apt the joy head of his life and
the day gypsy had the ball 15 minutes
she's thrilled had a great day yeah look
at are all just like posturing like yep
this is my world just like but nope
those two toys they don't matter no he's
over here looking like rocket racoon he
says how much for the ball no get that
bar first come over we're going to
Emerald City Comicon stuff to pack for
that so I was up late last night because
I got like a timed quest in destiny and
it gave me a resource I really wanted
and you know it is what it is
but I guess there's a New Avengers end
game trailer so I have to do a video on
that before I leave so it's actually
pretty busy morning but I'm glad I have
videos to do because it's been it's a
slow week movie wise so I'm glad I have
pairs to talk about and regular is that
alright guys I'm gonna be at Emerald
City Comicon so you gotta be nice to
Vanessa you're gonna mind her and only
bark sometimes not a lot like not 75% of
the time that he usually do but bring it
down to a solid 50 okay
all right
we're on our way to Emerald City Comicon
that's Nathan driving and those are
suits in the back because we're
douchebags and and you know there's the
one day where you dress in a suit or
night or restaurant it is what it is you
have to some good places up here some
people are surprised in my Avengers end
game trailer video that a they showed
Tony Stark with the group and bi didn't
mention the fact that they spoiled the
fact that Tony Stark was gonna get
rescued in the movie I simply didn't
talk about it because I didn't think he
was gonna [ __ ] starve to death in deep
space and that be the end of his story
of figure to get back but some have
people in the comments section quoting
Street Fighter the movie and I'm just
loving the comments apparently for this
video that's how you get your comment
loved is quote relatively a Zangief or
guile but we're a few gin and tonics
deep [ __ ] I can't do this in philip
ascent or alvin alright Nathan and I are
at the end of Mario 3 and it dawns on me
what if Bowser isn't stealing Mario's
girlfriend and Mario isn't rescuing his
girlfriend what if Mario keeps stealing
Bowser's girlfriend from his home and
Bowser just keeps rescuing her what if
Mario is the bad guy like we've been
playing as the bad guy for all these
years think about it I think we cracked
the company I think we deconstructed the
reality of Bowser its Bowser's rhaegar
targaryen
and peach is Lyanna stark and just the
story has just been churning through the
through the filters [ __ ] this is the
reality of the Mushroom Kingdom
I just destroyed a man I invaded his
home and killed him
now I'm gonna steal his girlfriend she's
sick no please
I love everyone who sees me just talking
let me say people don't really know I
don't know I just I just do [ __ ] for
about like it like I saw I was talking
with angry Joe boogie we're like we're
just a bunch of [ __ ] like doing our
thing like people are like you're a
professional boy stuff I'm not we're
spinning alright okay so what happened
is this dude looked at me and he was
like are you and I was like thank you
for watching you but are you Lucifer no
you're not I was like dude thought I was
Tom Ellis which I'm not gonna lie that's
one smooth bastard so I'm gonna ride
that way for the next I don't know week
is that over cup okay but that felt
pretty good
it's 3:30 and we're like man are we old
we just stick there until 6:00 p.m. back
in the day never like how far call that
merges it oh my back hurts I need some
bengay he's some icy up alright so we're
going to El Gauchos half the hour
because that's a little-known fact a lot
of people have a Cheesecake Factory
but I just realized my fly was open so
every picture I took with a fan is one
of my zipper down so that's real we're
watching an Avengers infinity war in the
hotel because I guess hotel rooms have
Google chromecast and we were like oh
couch Oz is still open and happy hours
still on
I'll get that happy hour
this video is not sponsored by Delgado's
by the way we just like it it's fun
that's a mighty fun gin and tonic and it
won't be the last in the hotel watching
infinity war and he just got the soul
stone which means Gomorrah but I give
the argument no Avenger has ever made
that kind of a sacrifice unless I'm
wrong feel free to correct me but I'm
just saying that us alright so we just
finished it and corrected all right
Wanda Maximoff miss Carla wait she did
that was pretty big sacrifice evident
melt your boyfriend's brain other than
that those battles and the big takeaway
approximate midnight I'm just saying I'm
so [ __ ] pumped that during Emerald
City Comicon we get to learn about
galactic trade disputes this isn't our
choice by the way she's just TV it's TV
I put in Street Fighter with Matt damn
[ __ ] good this place is nice and juicy
and hipster didn't like all the right
ways I guess it's really good now it's
really good
yes this is actually a low-key and chill
compared to San Diego comic-con and
here's where we come this is the real
money you want to see something worth
buying I'm actually thinking about it
talk me out of it I'm just saying just
try to talk me out of it is it weird
that I find this space less scary than
that face like seriously we were in
Seattle
especially for a moment a comic-con got
it come to pink gorilla because you
never know a lot of people saying the
Avengers end game poster spoiled the
fact that Tony Stark doesn't die but
Mario dies on the cover of that like
that's a spoiler so which one's worse I
mean don't judge don't judge too harshly
okay I'm just saying I feel a second
Platinum coming on this game this time
for the Vita I just I have a soft spot
for garbage but it's good garbage like
Van Damme Street Fighter that was
laughing his ass off over here at me
whatever Adam does you be God in the
night not trapped
oh we get done when we hang out I don't
know sleight boxing around the edges but
you know life ain't perfect
the tesseract and you got a bath he
looks like a rat or a gargoyle I don't
know which one I figured this is vlog
worthy danger is not only relooking his
pot of death but he's also a little [ __ ]
machine so he's just like [ __ ] his
brains out and licking his paw he's just
a complete wreck so we have to boil
chicken and rice and basically
control-alt-delete his digestive system
so he gets better
yeah do you clean the house in the
florist because it'll look like Silent
Hill or something it was a [ __ ]
horror movie and I got back from Emerald
City Comicon today so that back to
reality doesn't even cover it the
crucible which is the PvP mode in
destiny to embodies the reason I never
do PvP in games I I'm cool with sucking
but like that's just my thing I'll suck
one player and then one player I'll
actually think I'm good balla behind the
couch
so gypsy is panting why you asked I'm
glad you asked because she sparked so
much she's exhausted herself she's
freaking out and this one looks like a
potted plant alright so you guys know
I'm scared of dentists and they freak me
out so I had these three fillings I got
them when I was a kid and then Dennis
was like you're gonna need to turn those
into crowns just because they're they're
old and they're inefficient and I was
just chewing something and I chewed on a
piece of enamel which was a tooth it's
like a chunk of mitis gone now it's
freaking me out it doesn't hurt yet but
uh now I got to go into the Dennis on
Thursday I feel like I am Frodo and I
just need to go to Mordor because that's
what needs to happen still freaks me out
and tell
you the crucible in destiny - it's like
everyone else has super armor but I'm on
license to kill mode so it takes like
one bullet to kill me dude rounded a
corner took a shotgun blast point-blank
to the [ __ ] chest or the head I'm
gonna say chest only because he lived
took like half his armor max do I even
have armor about to get that gear just
find out
cuphead is coming to the Nintendo switch
which is great I got it on Steam I
really enjoyed it but it's just so easy
to play it on the switch I was hoping it
would come out for this place you know
cut heads coming up for this which is
great I'm looking forward to breaking my
switch in half that's fun so it's a nice
sunny day today I'm about to film my
review for us lawnmowers are going
everywhere so if people hear that in the
video I've got this kind of good idea I
got the idea that you know filming my
video and then flipping the image
swiveling it so essentially people see a
mirror image of myself not exactly in
line with the movie but kind of
thematically there it's a new jacket
jack is pretty symmetrical so I'll be
harder for people to see that I did it I
just want to see who sees and who
catches the fact that it happened are
people gonna be like your face looks
kind of weird well let's see I feel like
this is the wrong shirt with this jacket
that I feel like a Henley shirt would go
better but whatever
we'll see who notices alright so now I
have the video in the video editor which
funny cuz I was like alright if it's
gonna be reversed I kind of want to have
my placement in the same place you've
you reverse it I'm gonna go to the other
side so I was like I think I stand up I
totally screwed it up and so now I'm
gonna be standing reversed but I'm not
refilling it so it's going to clearly be
different - what annoyed me enough to
where I'm gonna refill the entire review
because it has to be right like it
defeats the purpose if you can tell so
blatantly easily yes it starts this is
the kind of fun I have on YouTube so I
guess in my US review where I flip the
image to make it a mirror image because
it's all clever there's a section I
totally forgot to do
with someone in the comment section
found out about it a couple people did
devastated it was a good idea
damn it like it's nothing could be
perfect yes that's the flaw in the video
all of course pales in comparison to the
fact that I'm going to the dentist
tomorrow I'm literally going to hell I'm
going to the bad place on my way to the
dentist and I'm freaked out and Vanessa
who's promised to hold my hand
well she well the realization that she
is dating a big scared child hits her so
I've already apologized for that and she
said I was cute that you didn't think
well how'd you say it I said it's cute
that you think I didn't already know
that you're a big toe oh we're here
we've arrived
I'm gonna run not worth it
so done with the dentist I was just
funny because afterwards as always it's
never as bad as long as I have it in my
mind now I'm eating candy because I had
a bowl full of candy and ironically
there did not put a temporary thing on
the tooth and after I am back from Vegas
we will then the crown on the tooth I
guess so that's the plan and if the
crown doesn't work it's like right on
the fringe he's like we might have to
pull it we're gonna try a crown so I'm
pretty excited so I was just beat last
night I was really tired so I edited
part of my spoiler talk video for us if
I just went to bed but I had a dream
like the world ended I suppose not the
world but like a nuclear war happened
I've had a couple of those lately I
don't like that I have they used to has
us a lot as a kid because again I saw
the day after and the movie freaked me
out okay I just saw the Noob Saibot
reveal trailer for more will come out a
lot of and the fatality is pretty rad
and I like new sidewise so I like
looking forward to the game but I still
don't think it'll be better than MKX
but I'm looking forward to a game more
now you know like instantly noob saibot
just makes the concept of all of it
better also just found out Shang Tsung
he's in Mortal Kombat 11 and they got
khari Hiroyuki Takaya the dude who
played him in the movie to voice him in
this game was actually better than boots
I thought reveal I got to stop going
down this rabbit hole of Mortal Kombat
11 if I'm gonna get this video and it
did but that news is pretty sweet
so my spoiler talked video for us is
edited uploading and that is today
so we're cleaning because we're having
people over tomorrow for Vanessa's
birthday and I totally forgot that part
of the logistics of throwing a party is
cleaning for one I no longer want to do
this this is the kind of is the
manipulation we've hit that phase of our
relationship we've always told each
other
no I'm saying legit we'll go to Chuck E
Cheese see if it's [ __ ] Franken we'll
see if it's Frankenstein pizza yeah for
science also fYI we like to listen to
90s pop on the Amazon echo so anytime
you hear music in the background
don't judge I'm just saying I don't
judge you
I find it only fitting in my nerd room
to have the man himself looking over at
all if he's always here yeah Vanessa's
gone right now and I'm cutting onions
and they make me cry don't like cutting
these things DIY pizzas and pizza
toppings and chips and salsa these are
the things that birthdays are made of
and the cutting board with mozzarella
and a cut thumb yeah it's a birthday
thumbs up it's a cut birthday thumbs up
it's kind of blurry okay so Vanessa and
I have a it's like a running drug a
drunk daddy with duck but that's what I
have a running joke it's like kind of
half it's like a troll joke but it's a
fun joke
yeah it's so yeah and so in Christmas
and this time I guess birthday we get
each other guy fieri [ __ ] I don't know
why but we do and one year she got me an
autographed picture of Guy Fieri yeah
you gotta watch for the snipers baby oh
people like me who've been on TV at the
last second but this year so I found
this and this is her gift this year it
is st. guy Lord of flavortown and it's
pretty amazing and it's proof that you
can find anything at comic-con private I
thought I knew exactly I was like that's
ur critics or birthday present and
that's what it's gonna be so actually
it's a good picture and she wants to
hang it up where everyone can see not in
the bathroom with the autograph guy Yeti
picture that you got me that Christmas
it's not weird Guy Fieri's picture above
the toilet in the bathroom okay if we're
not weird
stop so Vanessa and I were talking like
what is it about like movie posters that
are boring like that's just Mary Poppins
face with some more faces oh oh hey the
Grinch's face and then there's
Ferdinand's face and then there's a
bunch of faces there's all the x-men
faces it's like why are they just like
faces of the new thing it's not
interesting flame that's neat
that's the neat steelbook cover that's
cool couch exhaust face like that's just
the first teaser picture that hit the
Internet of the Joker it's like
literally ripped from Google Images
that's that's just not cool it's a great
picture of them but it's not cover
worthy same with that it was the first
picture of bane
it's like pyramid formation pyramid
formation pyramid formation head Yoda's
face okay so we're at Home Depot
selecting plants it's going either side
of the door
and Vanessa was like well you know we'll
get them they're gonna die anyway then
when they do you get more plans and my
thought is if they're gonna die why even
get him die so Vanessa asked what this
is we all know what this is it's what
you do is you take your ring and make a
fist and then like put your fist up to
the glass and then say in brightest day
in blackest night no evil shall escape
my sight let those who worship evils
might beware my power Green Lantern's
light and then you get and then you just
kick ass
so everyone has the reviews of Shazam of
which there was the ability to watch too
Zaman Saturday yesterday but that was
Vanessa's birthday I'm gonna duck out on
that
so my streaming first Azam will be the
Tuesday before it comes out all right so
I'm off to my Dumbo screening but I had
a nightmare last night check this one
out so like last week I had a dream that
like the nukes dropped like literally
Seattle was vaporized
this is worse so I had a dream I took a
bunch of old DVDs like crappy ones
ones that I haven't actually owned like
the old tomb raider movie I never owned
it on DVD but I gave all these crappy
DVDs to Goodwill and then I went to play
some old games like Final Fantasy
Tactics then you know when you play gay
you eject a game from the console you
can't find the case to that game around
so you put it in whatever case is lying
around you'll just remember to put it in
its rightful case a little later you
know where this is going so I guess the
discs just some of these great games
were in some of those crappy DVD cases
that I gave to Goodwill I no longer had
the game discs terrifying if you look at
gypsies fur it looks like the Venom
symbiote is like No
thing off of her if you really just kind
of appreciate it I have a venom puppy
she's feel like water into a pot over
there but it's funny like be whatever
I'm a child okay tell me the first
couple notes in the Mortal Kombat 11
menu doesn't sound like The Avengers
theme seriously I'll put it closer to
the TV I'll turn it on like 11:45 p.m.
getting up early is my friend Adam and I
are going to Vegas for like is guys
weekend in Vegas which will be a lot of
fun the problem is there's no videos to
do
it's like Dumbo was the only movie there
reviewed this week I reviewed it
yesterday the next movie was Shazam
which statistically everybody is already
reviewed on YouTube so everybody's like
where the [ __ ] is your review of Shazam
and so uh I what should have been Shazam
then Dumbo and then hey that'll be fine
it was just Dumbo and I won't have
another review until Shazam next week
so I feel weird like I don't like it I
feel anxious because I feel like it's
some weird sense of anxiety since I
haven't done a video and basically I
feel like I'm gonna ghost for about six
days on my channel but also wanted to
talk with you about what we talked about
in therapy or a therapist and I talked
about in therapy rather but what's the
point of keeping it to myself figure
might as well share it with you because
it was really cool and really insightful
and I feel like it'd be good to share
one of the things she talked about she
said a phrase I thought was a great
phrase and I'm gonna plagiarize the [ __ ]
out of her and it's
sorry but the phrase was our weaknesses
are our strengths just used with the
wrong people or in the wrong situations
you know it's just because you have a
weakness doesn't necessarily mean it's a
weakness
it means it's probably a strength but
it's just not used at a time that makes
it a strength so now it's a weakness it
couldn't help us think of myself you
know generally I like you know fun
movies and they'll say big-budget movies
you know in the summer movie season is
the season I love when it comes to
cinema and that is it is a strength of
mine and that was a strength when I
started my youtube channel because I
feel like people were like oh wow this
guy is you know it's different than
other critics and that's cool and so it
was a strength and it remains a strength
to this day but one could definitely
argue every oscar movie season that
strength becomes a weakness and so I
just couldn't help but apply it to my
life but it was a great phrase that I
feel like a lot of people could apply to
their lives so I give that phrase to you
our weaknesses are our strengths used
with the wrong people or in the wrong
situations I thought that was great it
was really smart
another thing we talked about with
social media and I don't mean to make
this a social media bashing month or
anything like that so but we talked
about human interaction and social media
and here we are but we talked about how
social media thrives on what she called
intermittent reinforcement which is
essentially think gambling loot boxes
whatever is these things to give you
these little nuggets of possibility that
you get something cool and then you do
and that feels really good so you're not
really incentivized to stop so you just
keep doing it and it essentially become
it has the possibility to become
addiction and I couldn't help but think
of social media with likes and retweets
you know it's like likes and retweets
are a commodity out there you know
people say clever things and for the
possibility of likes and retweets people
talk [ __ ] in the comment section of
videos for the possibility of likes and
if you get a lot of likes that feels
really good and if you get enough likes
you can go move to the top
of that comment section that feels even
better and so I feel like a lot of human
interaction is based on that commodity
of that currency of likes and retweets
there's a lot of motivation wrapped up
in it and you can apply that really
wherever you want to when it comes to
social media but I thought that was
really fascinating that essentially our
moral dynamic that you see because
everyone on Twitter just postures their
morality but it's essentially I feel
like a lot of the motivation behind it
not for everybody sure but enough times
for me to notice it is because like ooh
that'll make waves then we'll get a lot
of likes and retweets but I don't feel
like people are fighting for a better
tomorrow like they're like people to
think they are it's for the likes and
retweets and making waves because that
feels good because intermittent
reinforcement it's it's like possibly
pulling a great magic card from a pack
maybe you will but you gotta buy the
pack to find out it's like once again
currency is dictating what people do and
where the moral zeitgeist goes and that
currency is likes and retweets I just
think about it then I just also get
bummed out but yeah that was therapy
today this is Adam and I and we're going
so oh god is so cleric beeps get silver
all right we're going to Vegas Marc
story short
which is why you don't have any videos
from me this weekend which is why you're
finding out about it now like a few days
later in the month of April it's all
good
I heard a beep which means gin and
tonics is that we're in Washington now
it's relatively early but we're in an
airplane to Vegas which is international
Vegas space don't judge I don't judge
you you don't judge me I'm killing time
and I'm missing augurs all right I room
it seems pretty sweet but this is the
winner baby yeah oh [ __ ] I splashed on
me I'm that guy walking through the
shopping center of Caesars Palace
recording myself terrible all right
Vanessa loves Gordon Ramsay which means
Vanessa if you're watching this we may
have eaten there but if we did I thought
of you the whole time all right
after careful contemplation we did not
go to Hell's Kitchen we went to we eat
so much we got ill yeah Caesars noticed
this so I think it's worth talking about
like we know at first I thought it was
walking behind someone with perfumers as
a fragrance or something but everywhere
in Caesars Palace smells like hot chicks
like everywhere smells like would you
call it
it's like a strip club or something or
at least the very least it's like you're
walking by the mall and and you're
walking right outside Victoria's Secret
Mangia Caesars I don't we need to talk
about the mind control that's happening
in Caesars via that the fragrances that
they're pumping in the air right yeah
that's crazy you think it works like
people are like hey it smells like hot
chick ergo it's like with this fictional
nobody that's around me wow that's
I mean smell that's nice it's just
unexpected I didn't expect to be like ah
who's wearing Fenella oh the hotel is
it's nice it's a good choice good
fragrance who ever shopped for a
fragrance at the mall the brick and
mortar building that we're in that's not
a human you smell good that's it looks
like I'm sending like a sexy video to
somebody hi Vanessa
what's up but that said I I'm more full
and I think I've been in a very long
time I hit the wall let's do much food
but flying here was pride right because
I mean it was we flew first class was
only see so we're available but where we
could sit next to each other so first
class flight so that's pride I'm eating
today hitting the wall feeling this ill
that that's gluttony so that's two sins
down we got five to go we got some time
[Music]
this is Vegas time well-spent so this is
compelling and weird and neat maybe
conspiracy theory ish but it's just it's
fact this is what happened right this is
what happened all right so we were
talking about how metal your saw was
amazing and Konami stupid for dumping
Kojima didn't my suggested videos what's
like hey it was a Metal Gear Solid video
like oh the great things about another
gorilla and I was like well that's
interesting and it kept scrolling and
another suggested video this is on
YouTube by the way another suggestive
video is a video talking about a Konami
collection like my phone was like no
Konami school here I'm just saying these
microphones we saw right so for the sake
of science been here playing night trap
on PS Vita and I had my feet upside down
what the [ __ ]
been playing night trap on PS Vita and
the game kept freezing and and I
couldn't do survivor mode it would
freeze and I was at the very end of the
game and it froze and I was like what
the [ __ ] so I google it I guess that's
just the way that the Vita version is
the Vita version is just unbeatable
because it just freezes and it was
released that way that's [ __ ] stupid
this is the dumbest that needs to be
patched because it's a waste of money
like it no one's gonna pay ten bucks for
a digital unbeatable game no one's gonna
pay the 35 or whatever for the physical
unbeatable game that's just that's
irresponsible Vanessa likes pool so
don't hate me but we're stopping by just
just because
it's pretty Crandon scale and scope
there's another pool over there
but in time why is no one in that one
all right so the next morning hosts
insane burger creme brulee shake
recovery is a pokey but pokey dish it
was a bowl but it's actually dish but
this looks awesome
I'm gonna crush the avocado Vanessa I
found your place I don't even care one
of the coolest looking places I've seen
rare books look I'm all done for
lingerie mannequins but what part of
these mannequins don't remind you of
Silent Hill or some [ __ ] too weird
[Applause]
I have one question why why did we do it
well because Vegas is all about good
decision-making and this is a darn good
decision right at him yeah let's make
good decision okay being in Vegas having
a switch with t-shirts on the desk
excedrin migraine headphones game [ __ ]
it's like the greatest representation of
my life in a nutshell coffee it's all
righty this is my life
just this picture and now it's Friday
night and we go out to eat a great place
it's called la Cirque and if you're ever
in Vegas at the Bellagio there's a
restaurant called Le Cirque go there I'm
gonna get douche eating a little rail
for a second how does a casino as
wealthy as the Bellagio have
entertainment overseeing the length of
the entire room it's that big is in the
wrong aspect ratio like wow and it
drives me nuts
so this really happens we're just
watching roulette tables like you know
looks are gonna be Adam just goes red 25
I don't know if you can see it you can't
anyhow 25 came up and so we didn't bet
on it British saying hypothetically but
that's how you get hooked on this [ __ ] I
really want to start reading now
[Music]
gathered at Caesars and front of Caesars
for somebody and I don't know move it's
a curiosity at this point we're standing
here like [ __ ] I want to see who it
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we waited there like sheeple I
thought maybe it was Celine Dion because
she has her concert here turns out it
was Lisa Vanderpump all right actually
when she came out I was like turned to
Adam who the [ __ ] is that I took no
reality television good for her though I
mean it's awesome
and I was like as someone who only
watches the crappy reality television
that Vanessa makes me watch it meant
very little to me but it was really fun
standing there just seeing the
presentation and like when Roman guards
that a guy goes like Caesar and lady
dressed like Cleopatra and announcer
it's actually pretty cool and we go I am
so not sober but it's only because I got
another one of these and I did the extra
shot bhagath I know it's not my fault
because she did the next shot and she
was like extra shot it kept pouring it
in
some people just can't handle Vegas but
not us not us Adam not us Adam and I are
all right we're a little intoxicated but
we're doing a deep dive into the Joker
judges Heath Ledger's Joker PC if I just
Joker is like a great representation of
the Joker but the Joker in general and
how are you want to take it as Heath
Ledger story Heath Ledger's Joker is the
Joker's human beings when eyes aren't on
them it's like the true nature of paper
I'm just saying it might be this talking
about I'm just sayin it's real
uncomfortable but real like I'm just
saying it wouldn't be captivating it
wouldn't be as captivating as it is if
it wasn't in the realm of reality if we
couldn't connect with it think about it
all right
how long has it been
30 minutes certain least 90 and we want
and we came back around and this is
where we were deconstructing the Joker
walking in circles
Sam gotta be good wait did I do it wrong
closest I could find to the next morning
post hangover chicken noodle soup it's
essentially Chinese chicken noodle soup
but you didn't have on the menu so they
made it for me which is really nice of
them I'm never drinking again
[Music]
and Vegas comes to an end today was
pretty much recovery yeah I might have
overdone it last night this is life
going you're not wanting to come to
grips with this so the ginger rail at
the emissary port was good and this
here's to hanging out and spending it
out yeah it was fun dude we got to do
this also we were deconstructing that
Star Wars Episode nine poster we don't
think it's real I think it's pretty
photos we'll find out they're in
celebration again my thing is
until next time I said that way too nice
like I was whispering in Vegas is here
I so got back from Vegas I'm back home
now
danger and gypsy are really happy to see
me and have this package in the mail
waiting for me smooth the group's record
all right so that's the month of March
that's the our March nearly an hour
anyway so thank you for watching it I
think you're sticking around and this
next part I feel like it's for you
maniacs who actually stuck around you're
the one that this would apply to so
Vanessa and I are thinking about like
we've thrown around the idea of maybe
doing a podcast together it's still in
the fringe it's still me
like we don't it's in the yeah it's like
in pre pre-production like what would it
be about like sometimes we're like we
watched shitty reality television other
times we have opinions on other things
and basically we just talk a lot of [ __ ]
and so we're like maybe it'd be about
that like maybe it's an aimless thing a
formless thing maybe it's just us
bouncing back and forth on the thing
that interests us for that day maybe
it'd be a little more structured I don't
know but the question is if we did a
podcast would you watch it and
suggestion what would you think it would
be about or what suggestions on topics
or suggestions on formula right that's
how to phrase it well it's gotta be
ocean it's gotta be a marriage you know
it's gotta be like oh we like it and you
like it you know and wool yeah it's
enjoyable for you enjoyable for us kind
of thing so any other question like we
did a podcast would you watch it but
other than that as life goes forward and
we're brainstorming that possibly there
definitely will be in April of video an
April Journal that will be here and
maybe with you half an hour long maybe
it'll be an hour I don't know but either
way podcast would you listen to it if we
did it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more I'll see you in April
which will actually upload in the
beginning of May
[Music]